je suis persuadé qu'il y ait un rêve en
chacun d'entre vous ici présents ce soir
moi aussi j'avais un rêve je voulais
gravir l'everest à la moindre intonation
du mont everest mes yeux brillaient
l'everest le toit du monde l'everest
sommet qui fascine tant l'everest et ses
8000 848 mètres d'altitude début 2015
tout est prêt je suis prête
j'ai réussi à mettre sur pied l'ensemble
de ce projet parce que je ne voulais pas
seulement gravir l'everest mais je
voulais également gravir le sixième plus
haut sommet du monde
le che ue à 8200 1 m et tout ça dans la
même saison
tout est prêt j'ai cette tension
positive qui ne me quitte plus cette
tension positive que vous avez à la
proche des grands événements qui me
réjouit le 25 avril 2015
c'est le jour du grand départ nous nous
trouvons avec mon conjoint norbu cher
pas en route depuis katmandou la
capitale du népal pour nous rendre au
tibet plus nous nous approchons de la
frontière et plus la vallée se resserre
et plus la route devient chaotique
à tel point qu'à l'intérieur de la jeep
on a l'impression d'entendre d'être dans
un vrai chasseur et soudain notre regard
est attiré par un énorme bloc de rocher
qui nous arrive droit dessus
ni une ni deux nous sautent hors de la
jeep mais où aller une avalanche de
rochers nous arrive droit dessous dessus
nous courons nous courons jusqu'à ce que
nous voyons une femme en pleurs en
pleurs devant sa maison détruite mais
jean affût des cris des larmes des
enfants qui se tiennent par la main et
tous se dirigent vers des cultures en
terrasse alors nous suivant les heures
passe et nous apprenons qu'en réalité
nous nous trouvons à deux kilomètres de
l'épicentre du tremblement de terre de 7
8 sur l'échelle de richter
une longue attente commence alors
jusqu'à la nuit
nous improvisons un bivouac un espèce
d'abris de fortune
j'essaye d'aller discrètement aux
toilettes
parmi cette foule les conditions
d'hygiène sont terribles en guise de
soupe et nous avaleront les quelques
biscuits qui me reste encore au fond du
sac
nous dormons tant bien que mal depuis
que nous sommes bloqués là je ne cesse
de demander à norbourg mais est ce que
le timing pour nos deux expéditions
tient toujours
j'ai surmonté tellement défia
d'obstacles pour mettre sur pied ce
projet j'ai même quitté mon travail
d'avocate au tribunal arbitral du sport
pour réaliser le projet je me suis tant
battus et voilà qu'on se trouve bloqué
ici sans pouvoir rien faire
bon ce matin nous allons bien trouver
une solution pour sortir de cette trappe
je commence sérieusement à être
impatiente étendue de perdre autant de
temps pour rien il ya encore plus de
gens que la veille
peut-être qu'on pourrait traverser
l'endroit où nous sommes nous rendent
sur la route a essayé de déplacer les
blocs de rochers il ya suffisamment de
gens autour de nous à mais au même
moment un gros bloc se détache à nouveau
en face de nous suite à une de ses
nombreuses répliques quotidienne de 5 à
6 sur l'échelle de richter
je suis stoppé net dans mon élan la
tante de vienne
portable la tension monte norbu a réussi
à trouver un couple qui nous cuir à deux
bols de riz par jour à l'aide de ces
poutres de sa charpente détruite mais
moi je ne suis guère rassuré je lui
demande avec quel os x cuisery
comment ils ont nettoyé les vols qui
sait qu'à manger avec les cuillères je
me désinfection cesse les mains je ne
peux pas me permettre de tomber malade
maintenant il ya encore ces deux gros
gros expédition devant nous ce projet
pour lequel j'ai tant donné et une fois
de plus je demande à leur bout des
nouvelles sur l'état de la route pour
lui mais question sont de la science
fiction mais pour moi elles sont liées à
nos deux expéditions qui sont encore
devant nous je me dis même que peut-être
nous pouvons traverser la frontière à
pied en prenant nos sacs à dos et en
engageant quelqu'un pour transporter le
reste notre jeeps sont toujours être
intacte mais c'est vrai que l'axé
respect rillieux après quatre jours
quatre jours les plus longs de ma vie
quatre jours remplis d'angoise
d'incertitude de ne pas pouvoir sortir
de cette vallée de tension d'impatience
c'est un gros bourdonnement qu'on entend
au fond de la vallée
un hélicoptère s'approchent l'espoir de
voir les blessés évacués renaît comme
resnais mon histoire de partir pour nos
expéditions d'hélicoptères s'approche
survole la petite plateforme que les
gens ont construit durant ces longues
heures d'attentes mais au même moment il
fait demi tour et il repart il disparaît
à l'horizon et là c'est la claque les
repasse et cette fois c'est un autre un
petit bourdonnement qu'on entend oui
c'est à nouveau un hélicoptère l'espoir
renaît l'espoir de voir partir ses
blessés refait surface hélicoptère
s'approchent se pose est là les gens
accourent de toutes parts essaye de
s'engouffrer dans l'hélicoptère
au point que le pilote doit éteindre son
moteur est là la crainte de ne plus voir
d'hélicoptères arrive et me tiraille
mais finalement les blessés sont évacués
je suis de nouveau plein d'énergie les
plans se succèdent dans ma tête je
redemande une nouvelle fois à norbourg
on a bien assez tant que c'est juste
pour ces deux expéditions et on pourra
prendre l'avion à katmandou nous rendre
au tibet et en suit depuis lhassa la
capitale
on prendra une jeep et on rejoindra les
deux camps de base un dernier bol de riz
et cette fois l'hélicoptère est pour
nous les blessés ont été évacués
nous rassemblons nos affaires et nous
courons vers la plateforme l'hélicoptère
arrive nous montons les portes se
referment une école je regarde dehors
et là j'ai de la peine à réaliser ce que
je vois j'ai l'impression de survoler un
pays en guerre tout est détruit
il ne reste plus rien je n'ai jamais vu
un tel désastre jeu
repenser à ce moment là à ce couple qui
nous a fait à manger alors qu'il n'avait
plus rien sa maison a été entièrement
détruite et qui n'a même pas accepter
l'argent que norbourg le lui donner
leurs données pour reconstruire une
partie de leurs maisons nous
atterrissons à katmandou en silence mais
avec une seule idée en tête aider ces
gens trouver une solution pour aider ces
personnes qui n'ont plus rien je ne
pense plus une fraction de seconde à
l'everest pour nous maintenant la
priorité c'est de pouvoir aider mais
comment faire où aller comment s'y
prendre nous commençons par rassembler
notre nourriture personnel et des
lendemains
on a la chance de pouvoir se rendre dans
un petit village et distribué ce que
nous avons en même temps un soutien
exceptionnel se met en place depuis la
suisse des dons affluent sur notre petit
sur le compte de notre petite
association butterfly project un projet
après l'autre se met sur pied non vous
trouve des solutions pour acheter de la
nourriture pour trouver des moyens pour
nous rendre dans ces villages éloignés
de katmandou à des heures de voiture
dans des vallées où on a le risque de se
faire bloquer à nouveau parce que ces
secousses ses répliques de 5 à 6 sur
l'échelle de richter n'ont pas cessé
elles sont quotidiennes non on n'a pas
le temps de penser il faut qu'on agisse
nous fonctionnons comme des automates
il n'y a pas de temps à perdre la
mousson approche à grands pas il ya
encore tellement de choses à faire tout
devient plus compliqué notre
responsabilité augmente mais peu importe
notre priorité est désormais d'aider
d'aider ces gens après 45 jours des
d'intensives plus de trente et une tonne
de nourriture distribuées 3 école
reconstruite pour plus de 500 enfants
nous avons gravi un nouveau sommet
de retour en suisse je n'ai pas le temps
je n'ai je ne prends pas le temps de
digérer mes émotions
il nous faut trouver des moyens pour
continuer nos actions
le sommet est encore loin et il ya
encore tant de choses à faire ce n'est
pas terminé
c'est alors que mon vieux rêve refait
surface
elles restent les vrais ce sommet qui
fascine tant l'everest le toit du monde
et je pense à ses enfants qui n'ont plus
d'école qui ont besoin d'une nouvelle
école mon énergie est décuplée pour
remettre sur pied tout ce projet nous
sommes le 20 mai de cette année il est
21h30
nous sortons de notre tante à 8300
mètres d'altitude sous un magnifique
ciel étoilé
commence alors une longue ascension pas
après pas jusqu'au sommet du toit du
monde à 3h45 le 21 mai je me trouve au
sommet de l'everest
en compagnie de mon conjoint j'ai
réalisé mon rêve
j'ai atteint mon objectif et je pense à
ses enfants qui ont besoin d'une
nouvelle école en même temps j'admire le
lever du soleil
nous avons eu un magnifique une
magnifique pleine lune pour notre montée
pour notre ascension et maintenant nous
admirons se lever du soleil
en fait j'ai accepté la réalité présente
j'ai surmonté les obstacles avec une
motivation nouvelle et j'ai toujours
gardé dans un coin de mon esprit mon
objectif principal de gravir l'everest
mais un certain moment il a passé au
second plan les émotions au sommet ont
été multiples elles ont été décuplées
j'ai atteint mon objectif mais avec un
but différent de mon coeur est désormais
c'est dans ce rêve réalisé que je puise
mon énergie pour les futurs axes du
futur actions de notre association
potter floriales project est d'ailleurs
une nouvelle ascension a déjà commencé
car 30 tonnes de matériel sont en route
depuis la suisse pour rejoindre le népal
pour reconstruire cet été une école pour
340 enfants
merci